[Music]
we all have our favorite cartoon
characters but have you ever wondered
what their face actually looks like
today we'll explore some pretty
scary-looking characters from the front
including the Simpsons
stay tuned deceive just how scary Peppa
Pig actually looks don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's check
out how some of our favorite cartoon
characters would look with a full face
Phineas and Ferb let's start with the
characters with the weirdest heads ever
it's just strange even thinking about
seeing their full frontal face but yet
here they are both Phineas and Ferb
really have some of the most unique
heads ever they totally make sense from
the side and give the characters a lot
of personality but they're completely
unrecognizable from the front just look
at Ferb his nose is basically a square
and Ferb's triangular head completely
disappears in fact he looks like a brand
new character and you could never tell
that he actually has a triangular head
Marge Simpson we also have to talk about
the front face horrors of the Simpsons
characters there's definitely a reason
why most cartoon characters are shown
from their sides because all of those
features suddenly aren't that cute from
the front we'll show you a few
characters from the show but let's start
with Marge she always looks absolutely
flawless but maybe that's because you
never see her front face look here's her
full face completely removing her chin
doesn't it look like the weirdest thing
ever trusts us it'll only get better get
ready because some of these characters
are downright creepy from the front
Homer Simpson let's be honest Homer is
one of the most iconic characters ever
and this show wouldn't be the same
without him we're all familiar with his
face and he's one of the first cartoon
characters you learn to draw if you ever
take a drawing class but seeing him from
the front just makes this show so much
more scarier check him out we're sure
you saw his front face before but
seriously this never gets old speaking
of here's also a picture of what Homer's
body looks like from his own perspective
let's just move on shall we
although we do see some Simpsons
characters from the front Moe is one of
those that's almost always shown from
the side the grumpy bartender pretty
much represents all of us and our
regular day jobs doesn't he but have you
actually seen what he looked like from
the front
he's pretty creepy well his face doesn't
really look that good from the side
anyways but look at this his nose his
mouth his chin it's just all too bizarre
we told you these are some pretty
nightmarish front face cartoon
characters and there's a lot more to
come mr. burns
okay here's the final Simpsons character
before we show you a couple of other
front face wonders seriously you won't
believe some of them but first what's up
with this strange picture of mr. burns
don't worry that's not actually what
he's supposed to look like but this is
what's up with his teeth and when you
see him from the front it looks like his
long pointy nose is almost touching his
lips
it definitely paints a different image
of the money-hungry mr. burns and that
image doesn't exactly bring any benefits
to the burns we know Dexter remember
Dexter no not the TV series character
dexter from dexters laboratory we
usually see Dexter from the side so we
can also see one of his without a doubt
weirdest features you have to admit his
pointy nose is pretty out there and it
doesn't do him any favors that his upper
lip is just as pointy just look at his
front face picture he looks like he has
absolutely no mouth on him but a very
strange nose that looks like a beet his
nose is not fully front faced but it
gives us a pretty good idea of what that
would look like but seriously though
where's his mouth pepper wolf remember
hyper wolf from Rocko's Modern Life he's
one of the most colorful characters ever
but let's be honest here his full face
doesn't do him any favors check this out
depending on the face he makes he can
get seriously creepy but it's not just
his face pepper is just one of those
strange characters that will look weird
no matter what thankfully heifer is
totally embracing his weird side and we
absolutely love him for it too although
we seriously can't get over a scary face
he suddenly doesn't look like the
character that would love life as much
as Hepper does no thank you
hyrum woof speaking of characters from
Rocko's Modern Life Hiram is also a
pretty weird one he's not featured much
although he definitely caught our eyes
sure he looks like a semi-normal look
from the side but check out this picture
from the front isn't that just the
weirdest thing you've ever seen he looks
like he could be an airplane pilot and
definitely not just a regular cartoon
grandpa we do feel like his full face
makes him look even older than his
sideview
but to be completely honest this is
pretty scary if you ever wondered what a
wolf with wrinkles would look like this
is it peril here's a slightly more
recent character with an avid fan base
behind her who doesn't love pearl the
shy and gentle character is like a
mother to everyone one of her main
features are her gorgeous eyes and her
pointy nose you almost forget that she's
not exactly human but her full face
photo makes her look pretty scary and it
definitely reminds you of her non-human
side check her out we don't even know
what's scarier her eyes or her nose
suddenly all of her best features are
looking pretty weird poor pearl thank
goodness we don't see her full face of
you often Peppa Pig and the last but not
least is Peppa Pig
we had several videos on Peppa where we
discussed some things you probably never
realized about the entire show but have
you ever noticed that these pigs are
always turned to the side apart from the
fact that they have a pretty funny
looking face they also have both eyes
featured on one side of their face isn't
that just the weirdest thing ever so if
this cartoon logic is consistent it
would mean that Peppa's full face would
have four eyeballs
two on each side to be honest we're kind
of glad that we only see the characters
from the side and that's all for our
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]